lo que queremos hacer en este vídeo es
ver cómo podemos aproximar el valor del
área bajo la curva y para ayudarnos con
un ejemplo usaremos la función e igual a
equis cuadrada más 1
pensemos en el área bajo esta curva por
arriba del eje x que va desde x igual a
menos 1 x igual a 2 que es esta área de
aquí hay varias formas en las que
podemos resolver esto lo que voy a hacer
es descomponer este intervalo en tres
secciones iguales que en realidad serán
las bases de rectángulos veremos
diferentes formas de encontrar las
alturas de dichos rectángulos vamos a
aproximar el área usando tres
rectángulos con la misma base y veremos
diferentes formas de definir las alturas
de dichos rectángulos primero vamos a
definir la altura de cada rectángulo
usando el valor de la función en el
punto medio de la base lo vemos aquí
vamos a asegurarnos de que esto tiene
sentido para nosotros vemos que
dividimos el intervalo que va de x igual
a menos 1 a x igualados en tres partes
iguales
cada una tiene una base igual a 1 si
quisiéramos tener una mejor aproximación
deberíamos tener más
es más rectángulos veamos cómo podemos
calcular esto la base de cada rectángulo
es igual a 1 la altura la tomamos del
valor de la función en el punto medio de
la base el punto medio de aquí es menos
un medio el punto medio de aquí es un
medio y el punto medio de acá es tres
medios esta primera altura va a ser
menos un medio al cuadrado más uno menos
un medio al cuadrado es un cuarto más
uno es cinco cuartos esta altura es
cinco cuartos y el área del primer
rectángulo es cinco cuartos por uno lo
que nos da cinco cuartos lo escribimos
si usamos el punto medio para encontrar
la altura de cada rectángulo el área del
primer rectángulo tiene un área de cinco
cuartos lo resaltamos usamos la misma
idea para el segundo rectángulo un medio
al cuadrado es un cuarto más un entero
es cinco cuartos
los sumamos más cinco cuartos y cuál es
la altura del tercer rectángulo tomamos
el valor de la función en el punto medio
que es tres medios tres medios al
cuadrado nos da nueve cuartos más uno
nos da trece cuartos así que su altura
es trece cuartos y su base es uno el
área será de trece cuartos los sumamos
la suma de todo esto da veintitrés
cuartos que es lo mismo que cinco
enteros y tres cuartos esto se conoce
como la regla del punto medio pues
usamos el punto medio de cada intervalo
para calcular la altura de nuestro
rectángulo pero esta no es la única
forma de hacerlo podemos usar el punto a
la derecha o el punto a la izquierda de
cada intervalo esto lo haremos con más
detalle en futuros vídeos pero para que
se den una idea de cómo funciona
hagamos un ejemplo rápido aquí si nos
interesan los puntos a la izquierda de
nuestro intervalo en este caso el punto
izquierda es menos uno menos uno al
cuadrado es uno más uno es dos la altura
es 2 y al multiplicar la por la base que
es 1 nos queda un área de 2 en este otro
intervalo el punto a la izquierda es 0 0
al cuadrado es 0 más 1 es 1 que
multiplicamos por 1 y nos da 1 y en el
tercer intervalo el punto a la izquierda
es 11 al cuadrado es uno más uno es 2 y
2 x 1 nos da 2 así que cuando usamos los
puntos a la izquierda del intervalo la
suma nos queda dos más uno más dos que
es igual a cinco y también podemos usar
los puntos a la derecha del intervalo el
primer rectángulo vemos que aproxima por
debajo el área bajo la curva de este
intervalo su punto a la derecha es 0 0
al cuadrado es 0 más uno es igual a 1
este primer rectángulo tiene una altura
igual a 1 y una base igual a 1 por lo
que su área es igual a 1
el segundo rectángulo tiene su punto a
la derecha en 1 1 al cuadrado es uno más
uno es 2 x la base que es 1 nos da 2 y
en el último rectángulo el punto a la
derecha es 2 2 al cuadrado es 4 más 15 x
la base de 1 nos da 5 cuando usamos los
puntos a la derecha del intervalo la
suma nos queda 12 más 5 que es igual a 8
y con solo ver esto nos damos cuenta de
que estamos calculando el área muy por
arriba del área bajo la curva real así
que esta es una aproximación por arriba
del valor real lo importante aquí es
darnos cuenta de las diferentes formas
en las que podemos calcular el área
aproximada usando rectángulos y pueden
imaginarse que si usamos más rectángulos
con bases cada vez más delgadas que
cubren el intervalo desde x igual a
menos 1 a x igualados obtendremos
mejores aproximaciones al área real bajo
la curva que nos interesa
con esto terminamos